the only time you're going to get a
change is when Dana White's had enough
but to Dana why he's putting out other
fires dealing with other business or
he's just like we're just making money
don't give a [__] about the judge
because trust me if it became such a
problem which it is it became such an
issue where they started losing money
trust me you'd have a change in judging
by next week but it's just not it's not
affecting his bottom line so we're gonna
put up with it you're gonna take the
fights they give you you're gonna shut
the [__] up you're gonna take the
Judgment that they give you and you can
do nothing about it yeah you could do
what the SAG Riders do you just protest
but okay unless we see you're changing
and judging nobody's fighting and what
you do here's my here's my thought
fellas you rally the troops all right
you rally the troops and you do it
before the big big big event like UFC
300 the week of hey guess what unless
there's a chain we ain't fighting
guaranteed see some real changes when
you're actually fighting and you did
need the money right would you do the
protesters absolutely not
hahaha yeah